Ciao ragazzi e ciao ragazze
benvenuti al secondo episodio di "Una Youtuber in Cucina"
Oggi cucinerò una torta salata di
di zucchine
broccoli
gorgonzola
ricotta
parmigiano
uova
non so ancora cucinare la sfoglia quindi l'ho comprata al supermercato
facciamo bollire i broccoli in abbondante acqua salata
tagliamo le zucchine a rondelle
e le cuciniamo in padella con un filo d'olio
adagiamo la sfoglia sulla tortiera
tagliando la sfoglia in eccesso
prima di procedere con il ripieno
dobbiamo ricordarci di preriscaldare il forno a 200 gradi
versiamo i broccoli e le zucchine in una terrina
aggiungiamo 250 grammi di ricotta
due uova
e mescoliamo bene
infine aggiungiamo 2/3 cucchiai di gorgonzola
e un bel pó di parmigiano grattugiato o a scaglie
mescoliamo bene tutti gli ingredienti
e questo é ció che otterremo
versiamo il composto omogeneo nella tortiera
informiamo la torta per 20/25 minuti a 200 gradi
senza dimenticare di posizionare la torta nella parte bassa del forno
togliamo la torta dal forno e aspettiamo che si raffreddi
ed ecco qui la nostra torta salata!
buon appetito!